a federal judge is deciding who can
access documents seized from president
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
investigators are looking at whether
Cohen violated election laws in a court
hearing yesterday the judge ordered
prosecutors to put the material into a
searchable database to be shared with
defense attorneys Michael Cohen's lawyer
revealed in the hearing that Fox News
host sean hannity is also a cohen client
hannity a big Trump supporters strongly
criticized the FBI raid Cohen has also
been a guest on his program several
times last night attorney Alan
Dershowitz told hannity that he made a
mistake I really think that you should
have disclosed your relationship with
Cohen when you talked about him on this
show you could have said just that you
would ask them for advice or whatever
but I think it would have been much much
better had you disclosed that
relationship you professor deal with us
later I understand you should have said
that later on Hannity defended his ties
to Cohen Michael Cole never represented
me in any legal matter
I never retained his services I never
received an invoice I never paid Michael
Cohen for legal fees I did have
occasional brief conversations with
Michael Kohn he's a great attorney about
legal questions I had hannity said he
discussed real estate issues with Cohen
and no third parties were involved